oh stop first trailer is out for x-men
Dark Phoenix I did not have hope for
this thing even well before I saw this
trailer I am on record
a long time back I did a video not only
did this go on my list of movies that I
was pretty sure was gone it was gonna
suck that I did at the start of this
year I am on record devoting an entire
video explaining why this movie was
guaranteed to suck the thing is though I
didn't expect it to suck in such a
familiar way or at least appeared like
that from this trailer I'll come back to
that though let's start with the basics
trailer is bad and I don't mean like it
looks like he's advertising a bad movie
like the trailer is it looks and plays
and feels like a fan trailer it has the
overlay voiceover and the rapid shifts
and cuts and stuff that like Vokes a
mood but don't seem to fully fit
together narrative Lee that you usually
get when when people make fan trailers
taking bits and pieces from different
movies and cutting them together to make
it all seem like it's coming from one
film that's how this trailer feels now
if this wasn't being trailer it'd be a
good one but I expect at a higher level
you know for an actual movie so that's
that's thing one like it's just not a
very good trailer it's dark and it's
gloomy and it's foreboding and it's
generic it is the generic oh
everything's falling apart trailer for
what looks to be the Oh everything's
falling apart franchise I was going to
say you know chapter but I guess Cancun
now so here's what I didn't expect I
have expected this movie to suck
since the always but this looked exactly
like x-men The Last Stand genus had this
this degree of power forever it was held
in check by Charles who also didn't make
her aware of what he had done to keep
that in check she sides with magneto
like this is the sum that Dark Phoenix
subplot from lowest and giving its own
movie but doing it the same way like
hasn't Fox been like saying for friggin
decade that they knew they screwed up
with that and yet they're doing the
exact same thing like I remember all
this stuff was was being all this deal
was being made of that they that would
just catch a stain she was playing with
Andrus so that meant there were gonna be
aliens they're gonna go up into space
now expected that to not work either I
expected that to still be done but at
least it would have been distinct and
different if they're doing the grounded
version of this again that's what you
did last time you already did it it
didn't work oh my god and okay we do see
Jessica Chastain and so far as I can
tell rumor and indication is that she's
still playing an alien but she's
obviously playing an alien just like on
earth so it's an artificial injection of
one outlandish element from the original
work I mean if you've never read the
Dark Phoenix saga proper a decent chunk
of it takes place in space like it that
I love you realize this or not there's a
lot of bizarre cosmic stuff that goes on
with x-men during certain periods and a
lot of that was going on during the Dark
Phoenix saga so you know what I did
think because indications had been
I did think that at least we were gonna
get that on screen again did not expect
it to save the film but at least it
would have made it distinct from the
last time they did this it looks like
the only thing that's different from
that from last stand now is it's been
upgraded from a subplot to the main plot
but you're still taking the same
approach that didn't work and it's not
helped by basically everything I said
I've said previously this is only our
second version our second film with this
version of Jean Grey we don't have the
investment in either her as an
individual or her dynamic in the team to
care about her going bad and the impact
on the other characters this team has
not been formed long enough and we have
not spent enough time with her for this
to pay off well x-men The Last Stand
didn't do it well it did it wrong but at
least we had had two solid movies of
seeing this team function and it was our
third film with famke janssen as Jean
and so it felt like a more proper
build-up this as a second time we've
seen her and like that like this version
of the x-men literally formed at the
very end of the last movie that is not
enough time for the betrayal of her
going bad tool and the way that it is
supposed to land the reason it works in
the comics is the comics that had like a
decade up to that point of her being the
good girl and then she goes way off the
deep end and it was shaking for the
characters and for the readers because
it had that foundation there's no
foundation here in just oh my god like I
I knew this was going to be bad
everything indicated this was going to
be bad I didn't think that they were
gonna make so many of the exact same
mistakes they did last time that's just
mind-boggling to me and I think like
this this looks unless I'm in a spiteful
mood or I'm super bored I'm not sure I'm
gonna go see this like it is possible
that like if it comes out on a weekend
where like I truly have nothing else
going on maybe I will
or maybe if I just feel like being mean
to something which happens sometimes
maybe I'll go see it but right now based
off this trailer I don't wanna I don't
want to watch them make the exact same
mistakes they did last time
again in a series that really should
have end well huh I would I was gonna
say should have ended with Logan and yes
it should have but I would say primary
main series cuz Logan you can consider a
spin-off I would say really should have
ended with Days of Future past and I'm
gonna choose to believe that it did cuz
the apocalypse was Oh God
so yeah I just know just a world of no a
world of pain just so much why I know
why because they know this is one of the
big stories that fans know and they
think well we have to do it and they've
never ever put the necessary thought
into how to do it well and they have
repeated all these same mistakes and at
the very least x-men The Last Stand had
the excuse that the writing directing
team that set it up bailed before that
third film which meant that a new
writing and directing team had to pick
up the pieces on a release date that the
studio would move was the result good
absolutely not but at least I can point
to circumstances and go that may
honestly have been about as good as we
were gonna get under those lousy
circumstances this those aren't the
circumstances more to the point there
have been reshoot on the rumors of very
extensive reshoots so this is the
quote-unquote fixed version what was it
before Oh Dark Phoenix the first trailer
what did you think about it are you
actually excited about this if you are
please tell me why and I'm jealous that
you can look at this and feel optimistic
I wish I could I don't like it's not fun
for me to get this upset over these
things and get this irritated and
annoyed I don't enjoy it
but whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it's a whole bunch of buttons and
stuff including a link to the page
you're on check them out if you feel
like it but remember folks the big
takeaway here is that you're the council
and I just run the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]